fantastic show tonight sean i'll pick it
up where you left off
i am laura ingram this is ingram angle
from washington tonight
the china bluff that's the focus of
tonight's angle
[Music]
will she or won't she so who's bluffing
chyna or pelosi
now nancy's really tough when she's
wagging her finger at trump or ripping
her speech up at the state of the union
but is she tough enough to defy both our
pentagon hand wringers and the ccp
now she has a long history of at least
speaking out against the evils of china
and just because china is a big economy
and because we have a big relationship
doesn't mean that the challenge to our
conscience if we don't speak out against
that in china we use all moral authority
to speak out against in any other
country with china's wto
accession is simply giving china a blank
check as it failed to comply with market
commitments in this while china has
charged over changed
over 30 years in some respects it is
appalling that its human rights record
has worsened
that's fantastic right i can't believe
i'm saying that about nancy pelosi but
now as speaker the house and third line
of the presidency
she has a golden opportunity to move
beyond rhetoric and actually strike a
blow for liberty
now since we learned about her intention
one week ago to travel to taiwan
powerful forces here and in china have
been trying to waver off with not so
subtle threats
the chinese side has repeatedly made
clear to the u.s side our serious
concern over speaker pelosi's potential
visit to taiwan and our firm opposition
to the visit we are fully prepared for
any eventuality if the ui side insists
on making a visit the chinese side will
take firm and strong measures to
safeguard our sovereignty and
territorial integrity
and of course when china barks
weak need biden flax flinch
no need to be mean president xi
that kind of rhetoric coming out of the
the chinese side is clearly unhelpful uh
and and not necessary i mean again
there's been no there's been no trip
announced um and there's there's no call
for that kind of escalatory rhetoric
what a weenie i'm helpful actually i
think it's very helpful because it's
always helpful from when the american
people get to see china for what it
really is
a ruthless dictatorship that has grown
so powerful it thinks it can dominate us
and it's helpful for us to see just how
weak and pathetic our own government is
of course in reacting to china's own
aggression pathetic
and even worse than kirby's flaccid
response is the fact that we're actually
rewarding the communist party of china
after they threatened the speaker of the
house
now biden is reportedly expected to
speak with xi by telephone on thursday
this is an absolute embarrassment this
would never have happened under
president trump
i'll tell you what the agenda's going to
be she
gets what he wants he promises nothing
and biden's coms team declares that
progress has been made
from everything from the tensions over
taiwan to uh the war in ukraine
um as well as you know how we better
manage competition between our two
nations uh certainly in the economic
sphere um there's a there's a host of
issues and this is a call that has been
scheduled for a long time
oh for a long time
well joe biden thought his long
friendship was she was going to mean she
would be nicer to us
[Music]
of course the man's never been right
about a single foreign policy matter in
his life never
and don't you think chinese intelligence
knows this
they knew biden was weak before he was
president it was so easy for china to
compromise the biden family with some
sweetheart deals piece of cake
and they know biden's even weaker now
the ccp couldn't ask for a better
scenario
a hobbled u.s president who they already
have in their back pocket it's like
taking candy from a memory care patient
well smartly prominent republicans are
speaking out supporting pelosi's trip
this could be a rare moment of
bipartisanship speaker pelosi should
absolutely go forward with her trip to
taiwan she might want to consider adding
a prominent republican like kevin
mccarthy the house republican leader to
show the bipartisan support that exists
in this country for taiwan
now refusing to bow to the people who
use slave labor to make t-shirts and
flip-flops would be the smartest
political move nancy pelosi has ever
made yeah maybe ever
the only question is will she let
herself be talked out of it by a bunch
of nervous nellie's in the defense
department
now biden already tipped his hand about
what he thinks
well i i think that
the military thinks it's not a good idea
right now
and our establishment's official
newspaper of record the new york slimes
published a story filled with
administration leaks that our military
is very concerned that pelosi's taiwan
stopover could provoke china into doing
something very dangerous
you notice that we didn't see any
anonymous pentagon sources or anyone in
the white house concerned about
provoking vladimir putin in ukraine
i wonder why
last time i checked russia's nuclear
power too
now it's important that everyone
understands this there are four distinct
groups that are opposed to upsetting
china and therefore insistent that
pelosi cancel this trip
of course the military establishment
knows that china is dangerous they've
said as much
this aggressive and irresponsible
behavior represents one of the most
significant threats to peace and
stability in the region today including
in the south china sea we see beijing
combining its growing military power
with greater willingness to take risks
about our military leadership current
and retired they're compromised
i'm not sure
what positive can come out of it and
there there will be some signal some
measure by the chinese in response of
pelosi visits not a good idea
now mccaffrey and company were
embarrassed with the outcomes in iraq
and afghanistan and they don't want to
undergo the kind of reform in the
military that's actually needed for us
to be able to beat the people's
liberation army
second of course there's the business
community they never want to provoke
china no matter how many labor camps
china's operating
you said we are a brand of china and for
china do you feel like you have to
sacrifice your values at all as a
company to do business there not at all
sir we participate in sport all over the
world including china china is a very
important market for us we're continuing
to invest in china and we'll continue to
invest in china
well big business entire agenda is to
make it easier for themselves to set up
shop in china and ultimately ship more
american jobs over there
third well the academics and the
universities they make so much money off
china remember the research grants the
swanky trips thousands of chinese
students 350 000 to be exact studying
here in the united states they don't
want
anything to jeopardize that that's cash
cow
fourth of course our regime media
they've always loved carrying water for
china
they know they'll be really embarrassed
for getting it wrong all these years if
pelosi goes over to taiwan
and is treated really badly by the ccp
so they don't want her to go because it
would expose their complicity
so all these forces protecting china
they already know that president xi is
evil and he's the single greatest danger
to freedom worldwide they already know
that
and yet they choose to do nothing
and instead well our military of course
focusing almost exclusively on europe
they know full well that she is a
murderous dictatorial thug
yet they choose the path of more not
less economic engagement with him and
they're contemplating removing trump's
tariffs the administration is critical
of leverage that we need at this time
so the ball is now in speaker pelosi's
court she never has been known as
someone who can be easily intimidated we
know that about nancy
but if chyna can get her to back off
it's going to be a crushing blow to u.s
power and our prestige it's humiliating
if the speaker of the house now allows
some second-rate chinese foreign
diplomat just issue a statement and
change the direction change the actions
that the united states will take because
we are fearful of them
we are in for a long struggle and it
will not end well with that kind of
failed leadership it tells every one of
our allies in the region the japanese
the south koreans the australians it
says don't hang with the americans
they're fearful
the problem isn't pelosi's desire to
show support for the people of taiwan
that's actually admirable
the problem is that from day one
the biden administration has established
a reputation for weakness and
incompetence not just in domestic
affairs
but foreign affairs as well
and this encourages china to bully and
embarrass the bide administration at
every opportunity
so right now chinese officials are
banking on a continuation of the status
quo
the slow but sure capitulation of the
united states
let's face it she thinks democracies are
weak and he believes that america and
europe will eventually become his puppet
states
so pelosi needs to call everybody's
bluff
refuse to change her travel plans
because if she does not
she might as well give she the strings
and that's the angle hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else